皆さんこんにちははじめ社長ですベイブレードバースト遊んでますでしょうか
最近の米ベルデですね今まで延べベレットと違って戦うと爆発してパスがバラバラに
なったりするめちゃくちゃ面白いレベルなんですけども僕結構遊んでまして結構遊ん
でるうちにですねそのあるあるというガールフレンドバンドやっててよくを受けるよう
なことがなんとなくわかってきた
ので今回それをちょっと棒針してみましたベビーベッドバーストで遊んでいる人は多分
共感してくれると思いますではビビるドラール
飾ったでは米ビルダーるスタートぴょん
me
さぁさぁねー
see u 1
[音楽]
defan
エイ2
しゃーない j
see to はこうしよう
[音楽]
米ねぇかいます是非
中まごう至急
ねぇ
can can see our
ドンッ
[音楽]
うん
can can see i こうしちゃう
th
これはもって苔はこなし
水水バー講師
ああああああ
どこおかあどうぞ
コアあるに消えちゃうとそうえーい
さあもう
時間なら
今日も買えるまずも会のそれは水開発て一回一回
なったらと思いますうわぁスカって釣れちゃいますよハーイだったらいいよ
したいくださいよねーっつう1号4
wh
r 4それ
あっちゅうまです共同かい出すなそうですかラストまっすぐですか
まずマッシュなんとなくなかったこれで関節が一番強い
言いかけ終え単独本当だったら即決シャーピーツーはこうして
えっも何かやってるいい色をつける
もう
あーヌー
amaran
食べた汝のまずのらしゃー
はーいいくぜ j 3 day わー
go
強いなぁハッハー
[音楽]
ブーバーこれ
夏れ
パーサーんシャア ane 125
しかーし
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
teal
me
ana あああっ